[Music]
particularly in our industry there
hasn't been a lot of big disruptive
innovation happening on the back end on
the supply chain we just think that the
industries in the paradigm of more
mindlessly producing than what consumers
actually really want
come on it so this is a 3d body scanner
[Music]
we have begun experimenting with new
technologies to create colors without
using water and chemical for sure
we have materials like this that's
really sustainable the white dots are
actually upcycle denim
[Music]
a creates a very tangible excitement I
think when consumers can actually put
fitting products on we just recognize
that the trifecta of fashion technology
and business are all essential and
complimentary
we aesthetics play a unique role in
society if we can't inspire change
bigger slower companies that have a lot
of approval and compliance processes
would not even start to think about
changing so we play a very unique role
in pushing the envelope
[Music]
you